One batch
Two Batch
Penny and dime
Welcome back everyone
This will be my brand new Punisher
Marvel video.
Apparently
he's coming back in the MCU
I think we all assumed that he was,
but now it seems like
we have some confirmation.
So I'll explain what's going on,
because there's a lot of confusion
about what was confirmed
and what's actually happening
with the Punisher character in the MCU.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes they just started
filming Daredevil Born Again
episodes, which is why we found out
about Punisher coming back.
Hollywood Reporter Variety of the big
trades confirmed that he was coming back.
He just the first official confirmation,
like they haven't officially
confirmed Jessica Jones yet,
even though we know she's coming back.
Of course I would episode videos
for all those when it's coming
because Daredevil Born Again
will be eight episodes during season one.
So there's a lot of people
coming back from the Netflix shows.
You also probably saw after
the announcement was released that Jon
Bernthal personally
on his Instagram, posted this Punisher pic
just confirming the news like,
Oh yeah, I'm definitely coming back
in as part of Daredevil
in the Netflix characters
coming back in all these Marvel projects,
like Kingpin is another recent one.
Jessica Jones is coming back, Punisher
is coming back in upcoming projects.
Rosario Dawson was specifically talking
about Jon Bernthal Punisher character.
So here's the clip of what she said. Okay.
So they found out.
Yes, I found out yesterday
because I hadn't heard
I hadn't heard that announcement,
but I found out yesterday
that The Punisher was happening again.
So I feel like it's my second chance
because it was the only one of the shows
that I wasn't in.
And I love Jon Bernthal, so let's all make
it happen collectively, guys
would
be so happy to bring Sergeant Paul
Nice and Frighteners back for sure.
So what she's saying there,
she's responding to a fan saying,
when is Nightmare's
going to come back in the MCU?
Because she currently said that
she doesn't have a contract with Marvel
like she's doing all this Star Wars
Ahsoka episodes right now.
It's going to be fantastic.
I can't wait to see all those episodes.
But what she's actually saying
is that she heard
The Punisher is coming back to the MCU,
and she's hoping that it becomes
an opportunity for her to have some scenes
with Jon Bernthal as Punisher,
as her clear temple,
the night nurse character
didn't actually appear
during the Punisher Netflix series.
Like that was the only big Marvel Defender
series that she didn't get to be in.
But after all the news about The Punisher
coming back in the MCU just blew up
last night.
Rosario Dawson did the obligatory
follow up post to address her comments,
saying the boilerplate I have no idea
will he'll be doing in the MCU
when he comes back.
Also, Kevin Vega and the Marvel snipers
were on that like white on rice.
So like they definitely have their snipers
put on her
first rule of bringing all those Netflix
Marvel characters back is
the actors don't talk about the Marvel
Netflix characters coming back.
So if you see reports from people
or websites saying that she confirmed that
there's a Punisher reboot
happening at Marvel, that's not correct.
That's not what she was saying.
So Jon Bernthal,
which is confirming what the trade
said, what Rosario Dawson said earlier
last year, he is coming
back, is very much like Andrew Garfield,
Tobey Maguire in Daredevil,
coming back in Spider-Man,
no way home, like we heard rumors,
news reports
about that more than two years ago.
Azami posting this video.
Charlie Cox, Andrew Garfield We're like,
we're not coming back.
We don't know what you're talking about.
But that's cool.
The fans think that.
And I did see it and it's a Photoshop.
Oh, yeah, I am Spider-Man
in my world.
But then yesterday, clearly
that was not a Photoshop.
What I think is actually going on with Jon
Bernthal coming back as Punisher
is that first Kevin Feige
was never going to recast the character,
so it was never an issue of him
like completely
doing a new version of the character.
And secondly,
it was more matter than waiting for
the right time to bring him back.
Just with the overarching plot of Marvel
Phase four.
Like what is actually happening
in the MCU in present day.
So the right time to bring him back
as you all probably assumed,
is the Daredevil Born Again episodes.
There's a lot of stuff
that they want to set up with that series,
so that's why they gave them
so many episodes,
so many more episodes
than the other Disney Plus series.
They confirmed it for 18 episodes,
whereas most Marvel Disney Plus series
only get like six or nine episodes
just so they can make all these contracts
early on and set it up
so that they have all the actors
and the characters that they want
when they get to those later episodes
that won't start airing episodes
till spring 2024.
Looking at the Marvel Phase five schedule
here,
Punisher could always come back
and cameos before that,
but I don't think we're going to see him
until the Daredevil series
at the earliest.
It's the same thing with them
doing a Thunderbolts movie
like Waiting for the Right Time,
introducing a version that team, when it's
the right time with the plot of Marvel
phase for Marvel Phase five
like they're meant to be.
Thunderbolt Ross and Val's
dark answer to the Avengers team
entering Avengers Endgame.
They basically fractured the team
like a couple of them died. R.I.P.
Iron Man and Black Widow.
Captain America turned into an old man.
Scarlet
Witch, had a total mental breakdown
and turned into a full blown
multiverse villain for a hot second.
So after all that stuff happened
in rapid succession, Thunderbolt Ross
kind of pulled a Thanos and said,
If the Avengers won't listen to the orders
that I give them,
like we already saw, The Avengers.
Don't care what he thinks,
fine, I'll do it myself.
And Thunderbolt Ross and Val's
version of doing it themselves,
doing the job of protecting the world.
Their way,
their darker way is the Thunderbolts team.
It it implies towards the end of Marvel
Phase five, because Thunderbolts
is like the last movie in Marvel, Phase
five that by that time
Captain America, New World
Order, the Thunderbolts movie,
the current state of things in the MCU
will be super dark.
For instance.
That's why the Daredevil Born Again
series isn't happening
till like right around that same time,
because during that we're also supposed
to be doing a version of the Major Kingpin
storyline from the comics,
like part of Kingpin's upcoming story
Threat, The Echo episodes,
and then the new Daredevil episodes
in the Born Again series.
After that is that he's going to be
running for mayor of New York City.
Think of how dark things are going to get
in New York City when he becomes mayor.
It'll be hard core.
That's the kind of environment
that Punisher would flourish
in the rise of all these villains,
like all these bad anti-hero characters.
Just thinking that they can get away
with whatever they want to.
And also the Punisher character is kind
of an anti-hero himself with more of a
light side alignment, like he's the dark
as you could possibly get as a character
and still think of him as a good person
or redeemable in some way.
And also it just makes more sense
to bring him back in the Daredevil series
because he debuted in the Marvel
Netflix series in Daredevil Season two.
His debut was also probably one
of the best episodes of Daredevil ever.
Just like their rooftop fight with him
chaining Daredevil up,
They use that in all the promos.
It was such a big deal
for those you've been asking
what's been happening with Punisher
since the events of Punisher Season two.
That's
the last time we saw him in the timeline
because we're going with the Dark Reign
vibe of Marvel Phase five
and they might have some Easter eggs
from the daredevil born again
Frank Miller storyline.
It won't be exactly like the comic book
storyline.
They're using the name and probably
some of the Easter eggs from the story.
They might actually replace nukes.
Character in that storyline.
With Punisher,
where Nuke was working for Kingpin,
doing a bunch of really shady stuff.
And because Kingpin
is going to be taking a lot of power
during the series, it just makes sense
that they're going with a more hardcore
vibe like villains being more violent
openly around the world.
The Punisher also becomes
a big part of that too,
because he's a very violent character.
He's a character that fits right into
that whole dark reign within the comics.
He was doing all kinds of crazy stuff.
He even replaced Captain America
briefly wearing the mantle.
He was like the stabby,
shrewdest version of Captain America.
Very briefly.
There was even a war machine
version of Punisher.
Briefly.
Like how many guns can we give Punisher?
Daredevil will have multiple costumes
in the upcoming Marvel projects,
like The Yellow is just the start of that,
so it'll probably be the same
for all of the other Marvel
Netflix characters.
But like really good example though
is like Jessica Jones and Luke Cage.
They don't wear suits,
like they just wear normal clothes.
Can we find a yellow shirt that looks
kind of like the old yellow shirt?
Yeah, pretty easy.
Part of the idea is that
I think that Daredevil will just be in
most of the Echo episodes with Kingpin.
They won't be in like every single
episode, but they'll be most of them.
And it's sort of like them easing back in
to the Marvel Netflix characters.
Like, we'll give you a little taste
in Spider-Man,
No Way Home, and then obviously Kingpin
in the Hawkeye series just a little bit,
then a little bit
more during the She-Hulk series
and then even more proportionally
in the Echo episodes next year. Then
obviously them in every single episode
During the Daredevil Born Again series.
You also probably noticed that Marvel
put all the old Punisher episodes
on Disney Plus,
along with all the other Marvel
Netflix series,
like all the Daredevil episodes,
Luke Cage episodes, Jessica Jones,
Even the Iron Fist episodes.
Yes, even You Iron Fist,
All those are on Disney
Plus now, and it's just hard to get people
ready for the characters
coming back in the bigger way.
Like, Oh yeah, by the way,
we're bringing these characters back.
Why don't you go back and you watch
all these if you skip some of them.
So everybody posts
all your predictions about Jon
Bernthal coming back in The Daredevil
Born Again series.
What do you think they're going to do
with the character in the future?
Right now, I'm just expecting cameos,
like smaller appearances,
kind of like the way they use them
in Daredevil Season two.
I'm not expecting them to give him
like his own solo series
during Marvel Phase seven
or anything like that.
I don't think that they're quite
to that point yet.
But like I said, Kevin Feige
is never going to recast the character
like Jon Bernthal is the Punisher.
It was the same thing with him
bringing back a version of Willem Dafoe
as Green Goblin.
Like he said that
when there was the chance
that they got the Spider-Man characters
back, like way back and Captain America
Civil War,
when he knew that it'd be possible
to do some of these Spider-Man characters
together, he said that he at no point
ever considered
recasting the Green Goblin character.
Like he said,
he always felt like it was Willem Dafoe.
It's the same thing with a lot of these
Marvel Netflix characters.
So like, even though we don't know about
Luke Cage coming back
yet, he's not going to recast Luke Cage
like Mike Colter will always be.
Luke Cage.
So they're just waiting for him
to be available to come back.
Marvel's next big series
I'll be doing episode videos for
this year
is for Secret Invasion with Nick Fury.
The scrolls that'll help set up
what's happening with this Dark Reign era
in Marvel, Phase five in Captain America,
four in a big way right now.
That's supposed to start later in April,
so we should get a trailer
for that really soon.
In it, confirmation
on the release date for the episodes.
I’m also in the middle of doing
Mandalorian Season 3 episodes.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channels
so you don't miss any of those.
Everyone click here for my Full
Mandalorian Season 3 Episode 2 Video
and click here
for my brand new Guardians of the Galaxy
three trailer, video and Easter Eggs.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.